321 vai rolar tudo pessoal aqui quem
fala é o dar que sejam muito bem vindos
amanhã 6 am o estrago de que mais uma
experiência um jogo seco olha só aqui em
baixo aí 60 quilos de gião 30 que os
nesta caixa 30 quilos nesta caso olha aí
tá muito cheio folha história é isso aí
muitos de vocês estão vendo aquela
piscina lei
hoje nós vamos encher a piscina com 60
quilos de gelo seco é para muita fumaça
lei mas eles venceram gelo piscina curta
ou sexual deixei muito mike neste vídeo
estão forem inscritos que subscreveu que
também já sabem a tvn para não perderem
nenhum vídeo foi lá vem curtindo muito
bom aqui no canal e ver sua reação com
uma pedrinha de gelo seco para só aí eu
estava muito muito suado para lá 321 vai
às suas pares ou continua boa está a
fazê lo em lei bem louca não só aquela
pedrinha fez o que fez imaginem só duas
caixas internos com seu samba dá muita
fumaça ninguém não era justo e eu sei
que vou fazer eu sou um ser viável se a
história é só para o senhor olha só essa
reação química outra desfilará caso
vamos levar o seu sexo agora lá tem
muita força e 30 que os 30 que um dia eu
sei que não olha só
olha só o que nós vamos fazer eu vou
separar as duas caixas pela piscina uma
taxa mais energia e outra caixa vai
ser-lhe mais perto vamos lá vamos lá
trabalhar muito ao chelsea e falei assim
hoje eu sei que sempre a mexer se não
acontecer nada nem nos temporada assim
quem já tem um ponto separa destaca
porque tem menos 170 graus meu é muito
frio e chamar assim o inter a fazer um
campeonato melhor e é bem mais divertido
eu olho com piscina no lei
o mec tem muitas bolhas só ficavam
loucas a empresa chinesa anunciou ele
tem uma pressão gigantesca bruxas e
disse acho que eu consiga estar lá
dentro e não só o que vocês acham que o
medo e acho que eu consiga entrar lá
dentro hoje não sei como isso vai ficar
muito frio ou eu queremos peixe para
pisar as pedrinhas não sair
eu acho que tem que manter sempre a
superfície qualquer forma vou trazer
outra caixa agora eu acho que não é boa
idéia é mandar um por um portanto vamos
lá para cá e xororó é muito usado no
banco é a mesma de batalha
esta caixa base para o início da china e
aquela taxa para aquela parte mais funda
e eu estava tudo isso ao entrar aqui
dentro da piscina com gelo seco mas
infelizmente porque a gente está em casa
mas mesmo assim vou tentar chamar alguém
para participar aqui na piscina e acha
que se o ronaldo porque eu vi lá em cima
no quarto então é não chamar ronaldo
ronald do gelo seco
a desculpa é que a empresa não foi nem
eu também lhe então olha o chamado
porque vamos fazer uma experiência aqui
eu vou deixar toda a região cerca de 60
quilos dentro da china há 60 quilos 61
3310 que tu orgulho de mim porque eu
morrer assim não vou acompanhar né
parece muito bom eu por acaso um louco
para entrar a bola mas eu farei biondi
santi frente a gente vai dar uma
aquecida meu então eu vou te convidar
pra gente dar uma esposa na cama
elástica mas nunca usamos a camelot bola
cruzado eu não consigo entrar aí meu
amigo me parece uma tartaruga de moça no
meio a meio
eu sou de um siena 3 2 1
já é muito alto e é na hora do pro uma
cei olga no memso i é e vamos tentar
mais uma vez e agora pessoal a luta do
século contra ronaldo não vai
acho que a gente está superaquecido pra
pular na piscina memória agora só posso
lá na china
estou muito cansado só fizeram ver um
vídeo dedicado só a cama elástica
comentei embora lá pessoal despejar aqui
os nossos primeiros 30 quilos de um
cerco na piscina no trecho 2 vai muito
além disso está fazendo muita fumaça
[Aplausos]
agora vamos ganhar embora 321 bairro
ai ai eu tenho medo
por isso mano não poderá contar com os
pilares sério
como assim gil seco é o futebol então
muito dióxido de carbono junto com o
toque de gênio píton é muito difícil
respirar aqui
sério eu vi o filme é muito difícil é
muito assim como seus saltos e agora
briga eu nunca vi isso eu gosto mauro é
muito luta não te vejo na abertura da
segunda experiências mais legais que já
fizeram muito isso levanta é incrível e
é muito louca
acho que nem eu me perdôo pesagem aqui
tem muito muito pode mudar para o
futebol liga não era só vai abrigar não
só vai aqui o pessoal esta é uma
experiência incrível mesmo tipo jacuzzi
na china é muito grande ainda tem muito
brasileiro nenhum para nós
a copa do brasil muito lucas tá falando
muito ou o que custa mais respirar sem
cheiro de gás de coca cola e aí atira
mesma coca cola e é água com gás
a unificação é difícil olha aqui porém
esse filme era a idiotice março e ainda
trabalhar muito para atingir 15 de junho
exatamente queima por lei sua lista e só
vai lançar três procediam seco é isso
ele está me queimando problemas e é isso
que está acontecendo
primeiro eu tenho um seguro de camisa
a cena que me bola melhorou um pouco a
entrar mais de 28 mil e que a densidade
ele ficou tão pequena que ele bóia jael
bóia falei e ele como o parente quem meu
num muito louco eu só não faço em casa o
carriço é perigoso mas nós também vamos
juntos fazer o que são os cientistas
quanto no meu e tanto saí só vocês não
consegui ver você deixar ele na minha
mão está aqui americana aol esquema mais
do que inteiro porque acho que como já
tem água já tirou lhe o contrato de
desempenho muito ruim ou outra que
velasquez que a china tem algo aí
ronaldo é ronaldo desafio assim vou
deixar que esta caixa e temos que andar
por cima não ok advogados assim soma
isso teve que saltar de uma ponta à
outra e estávamos lá só para perguntar
32 foi seu substituto
meu quebrou tudo pro tudo ali isso em
jogo neste momento não me conheciam não
explodiu
a china está tudo sujo com a nossa mãe
empurra piloto alega não haver vtn vtn a
nova prova só no futuro um branco aí
o tubarão aí que só esta foi a piscina
do dia eu sei que aqui na casa do egito
vai ser obrigado na hora eu dar que
brigamos ganhou tudo foi muito louco é
melhor jurei é uma espécie muito louca
muito em cima vocês podem ver os vídeos
entre os também deputados passam aqui em
baixo mas podem sacramento aqui no canal
da av já não só como é estimular que
fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]
olha isso o tubarão